tom palisaro from nfl.com and nfl
network is taking time out no producer
he's in green bay by himself and the
poor guy calls into this
all right tom how do you feel about
benefer because chris brockman wants to
free
ben affleck he's upset about the fact
that he's on a yacht
with j.lo how do you feel about that
forget about aaron rodgers somebody
as somebody who just turned 40 and i'm
in a perpetual state
of late 1990s early 2000s nostalgia i'm
all for us running back things that were
cool in 2001
i mean do you feel bad for ben affleck
is he he's on a yacht sailing outside of
san tropez with a really maybe one of
the hottest women in the world
i know you're busy covering aaron
rodgers right now at a
green bay packers shareholder meeting
but what's more important than bennefer
i think you just uh stated it perfectly
there suzy i'm currently in green bay
wisconsin covering a packers shareholder
meeting
sounds pretty good not that i'm not uh
grateful i'll be covering another uh
training camp and doing all of our
inside training camp live stuff on
nfl network and all that but not always
uh it's pretty much better than anything
else
yeah trump's green bay i'm not saying i
feel bad for ben affleck i'm saying like
this is probably not
the healthiest thing for him to be back
in this situation
tom he's really worried about about
ben's health
i'm worried about chris's health about
benson
all right poor tom he's like why did i
agree to do this
ben went back after making one movie
making geely with her and made another
one so i'd say he's a gun for punishment
much like the packers and speaking of
glenda's punishment
speaking of glenn for punishment i
should have done the uh camera turn like
bryant on that one
uh what what is happening there because
mike del tufa was a shareholder
of the green bay packers he's an owner
tom and he would love you to give him a
feeling as to what the heck is happening
there
not as much as uh certain people were
probably expecting to happen today in
fact i just got out of
uh tigers president ceo mark murphy's
press conference in which he
he mentioned he thought i thought there
would be a lot more buoy
whether it was against us or against
aaron rodgers
uh it was pretty tame honestly there
were about four thousand
uh packers shareholders at the meeting
it was in the lambeau field bowl it was
90 plus degrees everybody's out there
bacon in the heat but
outside of a few guys you know yelling
little things of where's aaron and
you know uh murphy was complimenting the
general manager brian good acounts and
some guy yelled like i've never seen him
throw a pass
other than that it was like nobody you
know this people didn't pile on it
wasn't a
you know mob scene in there you know it
was like i said pretty
a pretty tame atmosphere you know we got
a few answers for mark murphy wouldn't
dive into
you know aaron rodgers coming back he
said he does not know if he's going to
report
uh tomorrow uh be here for practice on
wednesday i also asked him do you know
or do you have a criminal be here week
one
where he said he wouldn't get into that
either uh he did
say that yeah they've gotten phone calls
but they've been you know very clear
that they're not trading aaron rodgers
and i said mark so just to be clear
there's no scenario in your head down
the line
where you would consider trading rogers
and he said no absolutely not
so you know that's been very consistent
both publicly and privately
throughout this entire uh off season
this entire ordeal
it's really been a matter of how does
aaron rodgers
come back to the packers or is he
willing to execute his
one um biggest piece of leverage which
is not
showing up at all you know there's still
different levers the rogers can pull
uh he could choose to show up of course
on his current contract
he could continue to push for a revised
contract that as we've talked about for
months now would give him more power and
control over
uh how his career in green bay ends he
could of course you know
announce that he's retiring and
eventually on retire and go down that
road he could show up
five days into training camp eat five
days of fifty thousand dollar fines and
you know preserve his uh the bonus money
that they could go after
there's a lot of different scenarios um
you know certainly
there is some level of optimism into
here mark murphy bright good couldn't
say it today
i mean they talked about it in the
shareholders meeting as if
this is just what's going to happen
looking forward to coming back
strong offensive nucleus led by aaron
rodgers and we're gonna go try to finish
the job after going to straight fc
championship games you know that's their
external messaging but as we know
rogers for as little as he has said
publicly
has done an awfully good job for months
now of making clear
uh how exactly he's feeling about the
packers organization
he's tom pelicero the reporter for nfl
network and nfl.com i'm susie schuster
in for rich eisen
tom do you think anybody outside of
david dunn
his agent and aaron rodgers maybe
shailene woodley
do you think anybody knows what's going
to happen
that's a great point suzy i i've talked
about this a little bit on tv is aaron
is known even to people that he's close
with is just a very
calculated individual you know everybody
says like you know we know he has a plan
but he hasn't told us what the plan is
and so you know from his coaches on down
everybody's kind of been wondering
exactly how this is going to play out
in the background you know floam people
out there to meet with them and talk
about the future and
and everything else but you know it's
not i think that the
one of the mistakes we make in a
situation like this is looking at the
binary construct of either he shows up
or he doesn't it comes back to the
packers everything is great
or he doesn't come back and it's a you
know it's a disaster like
there's a lot of shades of gray you can
go through here the question really
you know i i think primarily has been is
this sustainable
in other words regardless of what
happens in 2021
where is this relationship headed is
there any way that the packers can
salvage it
in terms of long term or is this as uh
rogers alluded to with his uh his posts
along
with devante adams on instagram over the
weekend is this his last dance
is this his one year bleep you tour i'm
gonna go out and win
and play great and we're gonna win the
super bowl and then i'm out of here
um you know that's kind of always been
the most logical way this entire thing
plays out just because the packers if
they want to and they certainly have to
this point
can say listen we we hear what you're
saying we want to fix it we want to fix
the sierra quarterback for the long term
and if you're not happy with the fixes
well we still have the under contract
for three years so no we're not going to
trade you we expect you
to be a part of this team and what
rogers wants is the security it's not
the financial security
the guys made a ton of money is that
security
that he will not have to wake up one day
and find out his career
uh with the packers is over or find
himself in a similar spot to brett favre
uh when i was covering that back
whatever that was thirteen years ago now
where
far felt pressured to make a decision
about his future and you know shortly
after the nc championship game after the
2007 season
he came out and said i'm retired in less
than a month he was having second
thoughts not the rogers would go that
dirt that direction but
you know when far came back and said you
know what guys i do want to play the
packers said yeah
that's that's not gonna happen but
rogers wants to have something that very
few
athletes and specifically nfl players
have which is the ability to call his
own
shot on how things come to an end with
his long time team
and why wouldn't he want the exact same
thing that tom brady has i mean
let's face it he's also a once
once-in-a-lifetime kind of player
he's smart he's calculated he's seeing
tom brady go ahead and rebuild a team in
his own image and
why wouldn't he want the same thing
well that's where the patriots landed
too which was
they were doing something to tom brady's
contract at the end which was moving
money up
uh adding incentives allowing him to
you know make his money now but also uh
set up the contract in such a way that
regardless tom brady was going to hit
the free agent market even if he had
agreed
with the patriots they could not redo
his deal until after free agency open
so yeah you know the difference there
was tom brady for a long time
was not making top of the market uh type
of money and
essentially played out his deal with
rogers if you're talking about i know
that uh you know a couple of my
colleagues tweeted about this earlier
if you're talking about going to it's a
one-year deal the rest of it voids
i mean i mention that scenario to
another general manager has been
interested in that this morning he goes
why in the world would the packers do
that and i said i don't think
this is not their idea this could be a
potential solution from roger's side
it's just
it's very delicate and again you know
the rogers had a plan for his entire
offseason
he's told other players i'm gonna be out
of there you know but
at some point there are realities you
have to deal with in terms of the
contract in terms of
the packers leverage in this situation
uh you know mark murphy didn't really
dive deep into it but he did reference
when he was asked about what happened to
parents not here he said was the whole
cba process and that entails again bar
in retirement it's fifty thousand dollar
mandatory fines
starting on day six training camp of
rogers is still not here
they can begin going after signing bonus
money which all adds up to if he skips
out on all the training camp at the end
of the season it's like 30 million
dollars
you're talking about pretty significant
financial penalties even for a guy who's
got plenty of money to throw around
yeah it's a lot of money to leave behind
tom pelisaro joining us here on the rich
eisen show question for you about
vaccines because you were really ahead
of the curve on reporting this
is this your partnership you think
between the union and the league to get
players vaccinated be
because i'm just curious about what
you're hearing in terms of how this is
going forward
no question and the nfl nfl pa medical
experts who
you know let's back up percent the
league in the union have not agreed on
much
for decades now uh you know it's been
the acrimonious
collective bargaining negotiations and
whatnot but on copied
uh there was a real partnership when
roger goodell and damora smith did their
first uh joint press conference like 10
years
at the super bowl so they've very much
been close throughout the cove issue
and their medical experts are very much
worked in lockstep on the vaccination
issue
everything in terms of the protocols in
terms of
you know the differences between
vaccinated unvaccinated players
all of that was if not bargained it was
certainly
discussed and they came to agreements on
it because
you'll hear the same uh rhetoric from
both sides of this which is the vaccines
are safe
they are effective and the best way that
we can have a full nfl season and the
part they don't say we can all make
all of our money from the first 17 game
uh
nfl season is to get as many people
vaccinated as possible the only piece
that is not
uh negotiated is you know the things
when we're talking about the league
disciplining teams such as if you have a
outbreak of
unvaccinated players that cause the game
to be canceled and cannot be rescheduled
within the 18-game window
then the team with that outbreak
forfeits the game nobody gets paid on
either team
but that was the case last year too if
the game wasn't played
no players would get paid the only new
thing is the forfeit which is league
discipline
for the club which is a slightly
different thing but yes to answer your
question
uh shortly it's they are very much
working together on these protocols
even though the union has wanted and the
league on some level has also wanted
to not have this be mandated to focus on
education
uh and incentives instead of forcing
people to do it and the fights
that would cause you know they've got
what 83 plus percent of uh nfl players
have already had at least one shot of
the vaccine
uh there's ten clubs that are above
ninety percent every club is about sixty
percent
these are if you talk about the
comparable uh demographic for men
eighteen to thirty four whatever it is
uh they're very much ahead of where the
country is right now
tom i i just wanna point out to you that
this may be the only show that you do
today where you can talk about
aaron rodgers vaccines and benefit so i
want to thank you for your time and i i
hope you feel special
in that i got i got several hours of tv
left you never know but yes susie i say
that
[Laughter]
thank you so much for joining us here on
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here